I'm Levy Rosman chess educator and
YouTuber today I'll be answering your
questions from Twitter this is chess
support
[Music]
revealer's app asks what is the origin
of the word Checkmate and what does it
mean hash that question hashtag do you
know wow they asked this question in
2013 I really hope they've gotten it
answered as far as I know the word
Checkmate is a direct translation from
Persian the word
shock would probably refer to the king
like the Shah and mat would supposedly
mean trapped Frozen or something like
that at urchman asks how do you become a
chess Grandmaster the Grand Master title
is the highest one that you can achieve
according to the international Chess
Federation and basically it means that
you've achieved Mastery at the game of
chess I'm not even a grand master I'm an
international Master which is the title
right underneath that basically to
achieve the Grand Master title you have
to have a series of tournaments that are
officially recognized you also need to
have a minimum ELO which is a rating
that quantifies your skill level of
2500. if you want to become a grand
master and you're watching this and
you're young you still have plenty of
time you should study as much chess as
you can you should play as much chess as
you can analyze your games over and over
if it will take time but it is
definitely possible at Matt Center asks
dear hardcore chess players was the
jargon and Queen's Gambit accurate where
the games authentically staged did you
examine the boards for Flaws in the
narrative the Queen's Gambit was
single-handedly the biggest thing to
ever happen to chess it was viewed by
hundreds of millions of people and that
is why they had to make sure the show
was super accurate apparently they even
had one of the best chess players of all
time Gary Kasparov fact checked so many
details of the show and I'll tell you as
a person that has been to chess
tournaments sat around tables analyzing
positions they did a really good job
there's not quite as much substance
abuse in the world of Chess but yeah
people do party at Japan Tudor chess
asks oh wait what's up Charlie why is
Magnus Carlson so good at chess I always
feel inspired when I look at his games
Magnus Carlsen is the best chess player
right now and there's an argument to be
made that he's the best chess player of
all time Magnus has an incredible
stamina he will go on for five six seven
hours and squeeze water out of Stone in
many of his positions he has extremely
good instincts and end game technique
and that is what makes him the best
chess player and that's what makes
people inspired by his games because
sometimes he makes it look so easy at
Buco Capital asks okay serious question
how do you cheat in chess the simplest
answer to this is that you receive
external assistance during a game that
you play if you're playing online you
might just toggle your tab you put all
the moves in the game that you're
playing into some sort of analysis board
where a computer will give an evaluation
of what the best moves are but if you
happen to be playing live face to face
you'll have to come up with a better
mechanism otherwise you're going to be
caught much faster so people have had
accomplices in the past or vibrating
devices in their shoe or elsewhere but
that is the way you would uh win a chess
game by cheating at chessify me asks
what's the worst possible move in chess
in general if you want to ask what's the
worst first move that white can play
from a starting position I think it's
the move move F3 with the pawn because
you weaken your King on the dark squares
and you disallow the natural movement of
your knight your knight wanted to move
there but now you've got in your own way
so you sabotage your own development and
you weakened your own king of all the
options that you had on move one which
was 20. congrats you chose the wrong one
at chess dump asks what's the best
opening chess for me personally the best
opening is the Karo Khan defense it
begins with the move E4 so this has to
be played and black now responds with
the move C6 this is the Karo Khan
defense and the objective of Black's
move is to try to put the pawn in the
center but not only be supported by the
queen also be supported by this Pawn
this opening holds a dear place in my
heart because when I was like 12 years
old I quit chess basically I said oh
this is too difficult it's not cool I
don't have any friends playing chess and
I came back to chess after two or three
years the first opening that I picked up
was the Karo Khan and I won a lot of
games I had a lot of success with this
opening I beat a lot of very decent
players and I play it to this day at
Contra points asks I want to get better
at chess what's the best way to improve
just play a million games or do you have
to read like chess Theory the best way
in my opinion to improve at chess is to
get the fundamentals down and when you
talk about Chess Theory what theory
means is the best way to begin a game
but it's kind of necessary because if
you're just starting a game of chess on
your own it's sort of like going to a
boxing gym without any proper
instruction like one punch and you're
gonna go down so you've got to learn to
keep your hands up you've got to learn
to move your feet the right way and if
you're not doing that in the chess
equivalent then it's going to go really
poorly at Breeze chest times asks chess
myths are there really three phases to a
chess game there absolutely are three
phases to a game of chess they are the
opening phase the middle game phase and
the end game phase the opening is
something like the first 5 10 or 5 15
moves of a chess game played between
white and black that has already been
explored before what that means is maybe
somebody played it some years ago at a
tournament at some point you enter new
territory a position that has never been
reached which might surprise you but
that happens as early as move five or
six in some games a chess game that has
never happened before that's called the
middle game and that's kind of that
stage of the game where one side goes to
battle against the other and you try to
overtake your opponent and the end game
is basically when like half of these
pieces have been traded off or all the
pieces are gone and it's just Kings and
pawns that's called a king and pawn end
game so those are the phases of the game
you can debate whether a position is
middle or end game but there absolutely
are three phases that's not a myth at
Levine Maxwell asks chess enthusiasts is
there a name for every possible move in
chess after following the world
championship the amount of names they
have for different moves is infinitely
fascinating like the Sicilian Defense
win Gambit rosalimo variation yes so the
way I would describe this is chess
openings are named after people or they
are named after places any given chess
opening like the Sicilian Defense
obviously Sicily russellimo variation is
named after Russell limo the chess
openings are the first five six seven
ten moves of a game also in chess a lot
of different tactical patterns have fun
nicknames like Fork pin deflection and
so on but those are just descriptive
conceptual terms and they're not
actually named after people or locations
at by Brandon white asks is it harder to
play with black pieces than white
hashtag chess basically what Brandon is
asking here is that white goes first in
chess is that an advantage it really
doesn't matter the truth is you're going
to play half the games of your life with
white and half of them with black you've
got to be ready to play with either
color now with black especially early on
white can bring out their Queen they can
try to Checkmate you in four moves which
is called the scholars mate but as long
as you learn to deal with early
aggression and kind of nonsense open
earnings you'll be fine in fact some
people like playing Black more because
they can respond to what their opponent
does so their opponent shows their hand
and now you get to respond with black at
Patrick Bet David asks who's the
greatest chess player of all time this
list basically comes down to three
people Magnus Carlson Gary Kasparov and
Bobby Fischer there are some people out
there that will argue for somebody else
they are objectively incorrect and I
will be the first one to tell you all
these three players dominated in
different ways Bobby Fischer was a
transcended talent and hard worker he
was better than everybody that he played
and it wasn't even close but he was only
world champion once and then he sort of
stepped away from chess Gary Kasparov
dominated for decades and Magnus Carlson
is currently in the midst of his Reign
if Magnus can go another six seven eight
years as the world rank number one there
is a legitimate case to be made that he
will overtake Gary it's very close if I
have to give you an answer right now I
will say Gary Kasparov if we recorded
this three years into the future I
probably would tell you Magnus at K
marzantowicz says what can we learn
learn from a game deep blue versus
Kasparov the match was basically the
turning point where humans could no
longer defeat computers at chess Gary
Kasparov one of the greatest chess
players of all time in the late 1990s
played two matches against deep blue
from IBM deep blue was a revolutionary
chess computer and it was the pioneer of
Chess engines and in the first match
Gary won so Gary was still at his Prime
and was stronger than his chess opponent
the counterpart the AI but in their
rematch Gary was defeated and since then
computers have only gotten better and
better and now they can fit on something
as small as a smartphone at official
fbma asks random question while playing
chess how does your Queen's movements
align with your overall strategy well
the queen is the most powerful piece it
can move up down left right and on an
empty board it would control something
like nearly half the squares she goes to
show you its power its foresight its
ability to jump into the enemy position
on the other side of the board and then
come right back but since it's your most
powerful piece it's also your most
valuable one you don't want to lose it
just for no reason and I would compare a
queen to something like the dragons in
Game of Thrones where they can be World
Enders they could burn fire all over the
place but since both sides have one and
any of the pawns can also promote to a
queen it can get really chaotic really
fast both sides have eight pawns and one
of the rules of the pawn is that if it
makes it all the way to the end of the
board it can promote it can promote to a
knight a bishop a queen or a rook at TV
preds asks Knights or Bishops so this is
a knight shockingly resembles a horse
and I don't know why it's not called a
horse basically a knight can move in L
shapes and goes one one two Gallop
Gallop turn and it's extremely Elusive
and a lot of players at 99 percent of
chest strength will miss the key
defensive or offensive resources that a
knight can provide but top level
s say that a bishop is better because a
bishop theoretically could travel the
entire distance of the board in one move
but personally I would say that the
Knight is better it's extremely
difficult to pinpoint exactly what a
knight wants to do they're super tricky
pieces top level this is better but for
most of you this is the better piece at
computer chess asks explain like I'm
five how do chess computers work which
is ironic because that Twitter account
is literally named computer chess but I
digress basically a chess computer can
see the future in two three four ten 15
moves ahead come all the way back with
all of the different possibilities and
all the different combinations and
permutations of moves which could be in
the thousands or the tens of thousands
or even the millions come all the way
back to where we are right now
essentially the computer evaluates its
probability of victory that might mean
the king is weak and I can tell that the
king is weak and I'm I can tell the king
is weak over the next 20 moves I'm going
to be able to attack it just things that
humans absolutely are not able to come
up with all the best chess engines in
the world are around the same strength
the best one which is stockfish will do
this process that I just described
better more efficiently and more
accurately over time than all the others
at Brittany magic1 asks in chess what's
castling castling involves your king and
one of your Rooks and basically when the
king and the Rook have a totally empty
line between them the king would move
two spaces like this king would go two
and The Rook would come right next to
the king that action gets the king away
from the center over to safety like a
vacation house if you will but black can
also in this position Castle long this
is the longer side it required three
pieces to get out of the way and how
does black do this black moves the King
two squares just the same way and The
Rook comes right next to it now there is
enough defense over here for the king
not to worry long term at
spy747 asks how would you describe the
playing styles of Magnus Carlson and GM
Hikaru in terms of a particular animal
this is a fascinating question and I am
very bad at drawing analogies but I'm
going to do my best I think that Magnus
carlsen's suffocating playing style
killing you slowly over time is best
compared to a python and GM Hikaru also
known as Hikaru Nakamura Grand Master
one of the most accomplished speed chess
players of all time I would probably
compare him to a Jaguar like the
elevated form of his species fast very
very resourceful multi-talented and also
very elusive at justify me asks quick
tactic from Adams vs fabrego 1988. how
fast can you find Checkmate in two white
to move I found it Checkmate in two
means you make a move your opponent
responds and on that second move you
deliver a Checkmate in this position in
particular white is actually really in
trouble because white is down a bishop
and the Knight materially speaking white
has a lot less but look at this powerful
control over this king the king is
completely stranded white doesn't have
any options right because if white tries
to get in with the Rook one of these
pieces will capture but white does have
this move this is called a sacrifice so
the first move here is Rook F7 check
black has no legal move here except
capturing The Rook for free with the
King you're able to do that because the
Rook has no protection here so blacks
just want a rook but our Queen now
drives into where our Rook used to stand
and this is check once again but this
time the king is unable to run anywhere
around the queen because obviously the
queen would get the king but if the king
takes the Queen the same way the king
took the Rook our Rook would now capture
that King Checkmate in two at unlimited
chess asks our chess what is the rarest
move ever played rarest move is a tough
one but it basically means just an
absolutely breathtaking move something
that you cannot find anywhere else and
if I've got to give one I would say the
gold coins game that Frank Marshall
played in the early 20th century where
he sacrificed basically three pieces at
the same time his last move Queen to G3
was just exceptional and people
apparently showered the board with gold
coin after the move was played at
chessmate app asks can you solve this
puzzle by Paul morphy White mates in two
moves yeah I solved it Paul morphe is
one of the most accomplished chess
players of all time and one of the most
famous ones he's the protagonist of the
Opera game which was a Legendary game
where a bunch of pieces were sacrificed
to deliver a Checkmate and he was around
about 170 years ago that was when he was
in the prime of his chess career one of
the things that he did though besides
dominated chess was compositions not
musical ones but chess ones and
compositions are basically fake
positions that have never happened in a
real game with certain goals and
objectives that make you think totally
outside the box of what you would
normally be thinking of during a real
chess game and this is an example of one
the right move here is the absolutely
fascinating Rook to H6
that move puts black in what's called a
tsukswang or a German word for basically
having no moves except self-sabotage
anything that you do will result in the
loss of something essentially if the
bishop moves to any Square we play Rook
takes Pawn Checkmate that's the move
that we wanted to play anyway but the
bishop was standing there defending but
what if black takes are Rook
well then we use the cleared out G7
Square to push our Pawn
and black as checkmated Boxed In by his
own pieces so those are all the
questions for today I really appreciate
all of you who submitted them and if I
have to give you any parting advice
before I go it would be to absolutely
give chess a try it's a lot less
intimidating than you think and there's
never been a better time to pick up
chess with all the resources out there
thanks for watching chess support